what percent of hello aliens once had a
nuclear war
with greater than 10 nukes fired in
anger so not in incompetence and as an
accident
intentional firing of nukes and um
less than 20 percent was the most
popular vote and that just seems wrong
to me
so like
i i wonder what so most people think uh
once you get nukes we're not going to
fire them they believe
in the power i think they're assuming
that if you had a nuclear war then that
would just end civilization for good i
think that's the thinking that's the
main thing right and i think that's just
wrong i think you could rise again after
a nuclear war it might take ten thousand
years or a hundred thousand years but it
could rise again so what do you think
about mutually assured destruction
as a force to prevent people from firing
nuclear weapons that's a question that's
a new
to a terrifying degree has been raised
now and what's going on well i mean
clearly it has had an effect the
question is just how strong affect for
how long
i mean clearly
we have not gone wild with nuclear war
and clearly the the devastation that you
would get if you initiated nuclear war
is part of the reasons people have been
reluctant to start a war the question is
just how reliably
will that ensure the absence of a war
yeah the night is still young exactly
this has been 70 years or whatever it's
been
uh
i mean but what do you think do you
think we'll see nuclear war in the
yeah in this century i don't know in
this century but that like it
it's the sort of thing that's likely to
happen eventually
there's a very loose statement okay i
understand now this is where i pull you
out of your mathematical model and ask a
human question
do you think this this particular thing
we've been lucky that it hasn't happened
so far but what is the nature of nuclear
war let's think about this
there is uh dictators
there's democracies
uh
miscommunication how do wars start world
war one world war ii so so the biggest
datum here is that we've had an enormous
decline in major war over the last
century so that has to be taken into
account now
so the problem is is war is a process
that has a very long tail
that is
there are rare very large wars
so the average war is much worse than
the median war
yes because of this long tail
and that makes it hard to identify
trends over time so the median war has
clearly gone way down in the last
century that a medium rate of war but it
could be that's because
the tail has gotten thicker and in fact
the average war is just as bad but you
know most wars are going to be big wars
we so that's the thing we're not so sure
about there's no
strong data
on on um
wars with one
because of the destructive nature of the
weapons
kill hundreds of millions of people
there's no data on this right so but we
can start intuiting but we can see the
power law we can do a power law fit to
the rate of wars and it's a
power law with a thick tail so it's one
of those things that you should expect
most of the damage to be in the few
biggest ones so that's also true for
pandemics and some a few other things
for pandemics most of the damages and
the few biggest ones so the median
pandemic so far is less than the average
that you should expect in the future but
those that fitting of data is very
questionable because uh
yeah what everything you said is correct
the question is like what can we infer
about the future of civilization
threatening pandemics or
nuclear war
from
studying the history of the 20th century
so like you can't just fit it to the
data the rate of wars and the
destructive nature like that's not
that's not how nuclear war will happen
nuclear war happens with two [ __ ] or
idiots that that have access to a button
small wars happen that way too
no i understand that but that's it's
very important small wars aside it's
very important to understand the
dynamics the human dynamics and the
geopolitics of the way nuclear war
happens
in order to predict how we can minimize
the chance of uh
but it is a common and useful
intellectual strategy to take something
that could be really big or but is often
very small and fit the distribution of
the data to small things which you have
a lot of them and then ask do i believe
the big things are really that different
right i see so sometimes it's reasonable
to say like safe with tornadoes or even
pandemics or something the underlying
process
might not be that different but that's
the highest possible ones it might not
be
there there is
the fact that mutual short destruction
seems to work to some degree
shows you that to some degree it's
different than the small wars
that that
so
it's
it's a really important question to
understand
is are humans capable
one human
like how many humans on earth
if i give them a button now say you
pressing this button will kill everyone
on earth
everyone right how many humans will
press that button
i want to know those numbers
like day to day minute to minute how
many people have that much
irresponsibility evil
uh
incompetence ignorance whatever word you
want to assign there's a lot of dynamics
to the psychology that leads you to
press that button but how many my
intuition is the number
the more destructive the that press of a
button the fewer humans you find and
that number gets very close to zero very
quickly especially
people have access to such a button but
that's perhaps
a hope than a reality and unfortunately
we don't have good data on this
um
which is like
how destructive are humans willing to be
so i think part of this just has to
think about asking what your time skills
you're looking at right right so if you
say if you look at the history of war
you know we've had a lot of wars pretty
consistently over many centuries
so if i ask if you ask will we have a
nuclear war in the next 50 years i might
say well probably not if i say 500 or 5
000 years like if the same sort of risks
are underlying and they just continue
then you have to add that up over time
and think the risk is getting a lot
larger the longer a time scale we're
looking at but okay let's generalize
nuclear war because what i was more
referring to is something that kills
more than um
20
of humans on earth
and injures
or makes um
makes
the other eighty percent suffer
horribly
uh survive but suffer that's what i was
referring to so when you look at 500
years from now that might not be nuclear
war there might be something else right
that's that kind of has that destructive
effect
and i don't know i it these feels like
these feel like novel questions
in the history of humanity i just don't
know i think since nuclear weapons
this has been
you know engineering pandemics for
example
uh robotics so nanobots
um
[Music]
because i it seems like a real new
possibility that we have to contend with
and we don't have good models or
from from my perspective so if you look
on say the last thousand years or ten
thousand years we could say we've seen a
certain rate at which people are willing
to make big destruction in terms of war
yes okay
and if you're willing to project that
data forward that i think like if you
want to ask over periods of thousands or
tens of thousands of years you would
have a reasonable data set so the key
question is what's changed lately
yes okay and so
a big question of which i've given a lot
of thought to what are the major changes
that seem to have happened in culture
and human attitudes over the last few
centuries and what's our best
explanation for those so that we can
project them forward into the future
and i have a story about that
which is the story that we have been
drifting back toward forager attitudes
in the last few centuries as we get rich
so the idea is we spent a million years
being a forager
and that was a very sort of
standard lifestyle that we know a lot
about
foragers sort of live in small bands
they
make decisions cooperatively they share
food they you know um they don't have
much property et cetera
and humans liked that and then ten
thousand years ago farming became
possible but it was only possible
because we were plastic enough to really
change our culture farming styles and
cultures are very different they have
slavery they have war they have property
they have inequality they have kings
they they stay in one place instead of
wandering they they don't have as much
diversity of experience or food they
have more disease this farming life is
just very different but humans were able
to sort of introduce conformity and
religion and all sorts of things to
become just a very different kind of
creature as farmers farmers were just
really different than foragers in terms
of their values and their lives
but the pressures that made foragers and
the farmers were part mediated by
poverty
farmers were poor and if they deviated
from the farming norms that every people
around them supported they were quite at
risk of starving to death
um
and then in the last few centuries we've
gotten rich and as we've gotten rich the
social pressures that turned foragers
into farmers have become less
less persuasive to us
so for example a farming young woman who
was told if you have a child out of
wedlock you and your child may starve
that was a credible threat she would see
actual examples around her to make that
a believable threat
today if you say to a young woman you
shouldn't have a child out of wedlock
she will see other young women around
her doing okay that way we're all rich
enough to be able to afford that sort of
a thing and therefore she's more
inclined often to go with her
inclinations or sort of more natural
inclinations about such things rather
than to be
pressured to follow the
official farming norms of that you
shouldn't do that sort of thing and all
through our lives we have been drifting
back toward forager attitudes
because we've been getting rich and so
aside from at work which is an exception
but elsewhere i think this explains
trends toward less slavery more
democracy less religion
less fertility more promiscuity
more travel more art more leisure
uh fewer work hours
all these trends are basically explained
by becoming more forager-like and much
science fiction celebrates this star
trek or the culture novels people like
this image that we are moving toward
this world we're basically like foragers
we're peaceful we share we make
decisions collectively we have a lot of
free time
we are into art
so forger
you know forger is a word and it has
it's a loaded word because it's
connected to
the actual
what life was actually like at that time
as you mentioned we sometimes don't do a
good job of telling accurately what life
was like back then but you're saying if
it's not exactly like forges it rhymes
in some fundamental way right you also
said peaceful
is it obvious that a forager with the
nuclear weapon
uh would
be peaceful i don't know if that's 100
obvious so we know again we know a fair
bit about what foragers lives were like
the main sort of violence they had would
be sexual jealousy they were relatively
promiscuous and so there'd be a lot of
jealousy but they did not have organized
wars with each other that is they were
at peace with their neighboring forager
bands they didn't have property in land
or even in people they didn't really
have marriage
um
and so
they were in fact
peaceful
and that's when you think about
large-scale wars they don't start
learning they didn't have coordinated
large-scale wars the ways chimpanzees do
our chimpanzees do have wars between one
tribe of chimpanzees and others but
human foragers did not farmers return to
that of course the more chimpanzee-like
styles well that's a hopeful message
you